9-1-1 what's your emergency
not again one of the new features in the
iPhones and apple watches this year is
called crash detection essentially it
can automatically determine if it's been
in a car crash and then call emergency
services for you so they do this by
constantly sampling data from a bunch of
sensors so basically if the phone's GPS
says you're traveling very quickly and
then the gyroscope and accelerometer
feels some hard g-forces and then the
microphone hears some loud crashing
sounds it's pretty sure you've been in a
crash so It'll ask you and then call
9-1-1 if you don't respond but you know
what else turns out to have almost the
exact same set of circumstances
happening to you and the phone in your
pocket a roller coaster people have been
going on theme park rides accelerating
fast hitting high g-forces and hearing
loud crashing sounds and their phones
and watches have picked up on all that
and started calling 9-1-1 sending law
enforcement over and over again to the
Joker roller coaster at Six Flags so
that's why you might now start to see
signs like this warning you to turn your
phone off or put it in Airplane Mode
which is kind of hilarious but also
Apple please try to fix this one